the International CES in Las Vegas is
widely seen as the prime home
electronics trade fair car Tessa Montes
kuratas in the chinese city of shanghai
for the asian version of the event this
is CES asia's first year with just two
exhibition halls it's nowhere near the
size of the original event but the range
of products is still broad and varied
Martha says there's no single dominant
trend at the CES Asia it has a bit of
everything loudspeakers for every
situation even for use under water there
are all kinds of wearables from
smartwatches to fitness watches drones
and droves and 3d printers pretty much
anything electronic there are some non
electronic items to like those bags over
there get some vice view he's a tough
many car makers and suppliers are also
here in Shanghai mercedes-benz for
instances here with its self-driving
f-zero 15 concept car Koba who Baptist
ruska of Mercedes points out that china
is the world's largest car market it's
also a market with more than 500 million
smartphone users very youthful and
dynamic so it's no surprise that CES has
come to China he says that some day soon
we'll be seeing new consumer electronic
trends coming out of China the day
before the fair mercedes-benz hell
detective for Chinese reporters the
focus was on the c/e and as classes plus
stood carts latest innovations in
infotainment and safety Daimler
cooperated with a Chinese web services
company bay due to develop the Bay Duke
our life system which will offer a broad
range of internet services in China the
intelligent drive simulator can provide
a real adrenaline rush
she's been off Maxim frog venom ona
mercede says he's not paying attention a
pedestrian steps into the road but he
doesn't react another car slams onto the
brakes all on its own he says sorry he
just didn't see the pedestrian but
fortunately the car stereo Cameron radar
sensors detected the pedestrian and
slammed on the brakes pony was the first
car maker to exhibit in Las Vegas they
also opened CES Asia with a keynote
speech so it's the perfect opportunity
for a world premiere Olli Hackenberg
says Audi is using this car to develop
their battery technology and they're
helping their staff develop rd skills
and these kinds of systems this r8
e-tron drove itself onto the stage and
it can cover 450 kilometers using only
electricity the battery can be fully
recharged in just two hours without ease
combined charging system that's another
big step towards true e-mobility and
that's not outies only innovation here
at the fair mata says that at the CES
Las Vegas Audi presented a tablet that
seamlessly integrates into the car's
interior it also meets all the
requirements for automotive use
including crash safety now Audi's gone
one step further and added gesture
control so all he has to do is wave his
hand to operate the tablet connected to
the front seat dammit that's template
bashyam photos it
stoya w brought along an eagle to
Shanghai it can autonomously retrace a
previously learned route to a parking
spot it uses only technology that's
already in the series including a front
camera and ultrasound sensors
CES Asia is a thriving transplant
bringing the Las Vegas Electronic Show
to China it successfully featured many
Chinese brands and many international
ones as well montes admits that he's not
the greatest drummer but this music cat
drum station might help you could see
how it works the display tells you where
to hit and when and then you just have
to practice and that's exactly what
Matusz is going to do right now
you